featuring plots made up as they went
along and Cliffhangers left forever
unresolved these sci-fi shows have left
some fans scratching their heads for
decades
Netflix's altered carbon ran for two
seasons with two different lead Stars
Anthony Mackey and Jill Kinnaman playing
the same character and that's the least
befuddling part about it a cyberpunk
thriller altered carbon is set in a
future where people can receive new
bodies and swap Minds much of the
confusion for this show comes simply
from its complex fictional Universe
where unusual political and social
structures play key roles new ideas are
often given awkward slang terms that can
be tough to pick up factions like the
envoy and the praetorians have motives
and agendas that aren't always easily
defined characters receiving new bodies
or sleeves thanks to their stack a disc
that contains their memories and
Consciousness is just the tip of the
iceberg but moving past some already
bewildering terminology and intricate
World building the series is also a
murder mystery that's just as compelling
and confusing as anything you'll find
this site of True Detective like many on
this list altered carbon is a strange
journey through a bizarre sci-fi world
that requires some focus and thought to
follow leaving plenty of audiences
perplexed
arguably one of the most disappointing
Sci-Fi series of the past 20 years Under
the Dome was based on an acclaimed
Stephen King novel and showed incredible
promise in its first season telling the
story of a small town that suddenly
finds itself encased in an invisible
Dome and cut off from the outside world
the initial batch of stories amounts to
a successful mystery and a suspenseful
Thriller but trying to turn a one-off
novel into a multi-season show proved
problematic as the creators introduced
many wildly different elements that
seemed to come out of nowhere to extend
the story this includes a war among the
townspeople an alliance with aliens and
even an episode that introduces an
alternate reality suddenly what had
initially hooked audiences as a
compelling but relatively
straightforward mystery and character
drama devolved into baffling sci-fi
schlock to make matters worse audiences
were left dumbfounded as new storylines
came and went with no explanation as a
result ratings fell and by the time the
show was canceled there were too many
unanswered questions to wrap up the show
in any kind of satisfying way but
despite all the unresolved plot lines
the ending of the show still tries to
shove in a few more in the last episode
a decade later Under the Dome is sadly
remembered as a frustrating sci-fi
Adventure that makes little sense
in 1978 Battlestar Galactica mixed the
fast-paced Sci-Fi adventure of Star Wars
with the wild theories of so-called
ancient astronauts it only lasted a year
but garnered a cult following that led
to a long-awaited Revival in 2004. the
newer series greatly expands on the
mythology of the show but for some the
added complexity just makes it more of a
puzzle in this beloved series a race of
sentient robots known as the cylons
decimates a thriving civilization whose
survivors flee to the fabled lost world
called Earth The Twist some of the human
characters are secretly robots in
Disguise which was enough to bewilder
plenty of viewers as the show tried to
write around its own retcons
or silence
and we have been from the start
the importance of a certain Bob Dylan
song also made little sense even when
they tried to explain it as some kind of
Prophecy but when you learn that series
Creator Ron Moore has admitted that the
cylons had no overarching plans the
confusing nature of the show's plot
starts to make more sense of course the
most downright frustrating aspect of the
series might be its shoehorned religious
ideas of Destiny and Faith which often
feel like exercises in Hollow symbolism
in the final episode a major character
is implied to have been a Heavenly Angel
all along and an attempt to hastily
resolve a series-long riddle suggests
everything was just God's doing for a
show whose initial appeal was its
grounded gritty realism it still went on
to confuse plenty of Hardcore sci-fi
fans
the epitome of serialized stories that
were sort of made up as they went along
lost starts as a plane crash Survivor
character drama but before the end of
the pilot episode the series becomes a
captivating Supernatural mystery as new
Sinister forces are revealed on the
island
it killed them
it killed them all
by the end of its run the story includes
time travel alternate realities and even
some religious symbolism for the most
part though the addition of the more
Fantastical elements works it's just
that there's so much going on that it
becomes overly complicated and as a
result fans have been left puzzled for
years while some audiences were more
than confused by much of the show's
story those with the Keen Eye were able
to follow along but with so much to keep
track of it often feels like much of the
larger philosophical issues at play are
left to languish the show's focus on
fate and Free Will kind of Fizzles out
and some plot points and characters that
are implied to have deeper meanings are
pretty much dropped altogether a lot of
this can be chalked up to the writers
acknowledging that they had no idea
where they were going with the story or
they kind of had an idea but had to
change it to keep Network Executives
happy not that it's any consolation to
confused viewers
the Sci-Fi conspiracy Thriller Mr Robot
Stars Rami Malek as cyber security
engineer and hacker Elliot Alderson who
was enlisted by an enigmatic figure
called Mr Robot to Aid in his hacktivist
causes set in the world of intricate and
complex conspiracies involving
monolithic corporations faceless
governments and shadowy agents the Web
of Lies and back alley deals in this
fictionalized New York City gets tricky
to follow but to add an extra level of
confusion Alderson suffers from serious
anxiety depression and multiple
personalities meaning he can often be an
unreliable narrator to emphasize
alderson's troubled mental state the
show is often intentionally confusing
even the show's most passionate fans
have commented that serious attention is
required to fully grasp the story and
connect every dot major Revelations as
early as season 1 proved mind-boggling
to many viewers While others insisted
that all will be explained by the series
finale but no matter how many times some
fans watch it through there's just so
much densely plotted action on top of
confusing themes that it sometimes feels
like Mr Robot is more trouble than it's
worth even those critical of the show
have acknowledged the quality of its
writing acting and directing so if
you're willing to put in the work to
understand Mr Robot you'll be handsomely
rewarded
running three seasons the Netflix series
dark revolves around a child kidnapping
that reveals an elaborate scheme by
Sinister forces that stretches back
decades between its convoluted time
travel plot and examination of The Human
Condition dark was called mentally
exhausting by Paul tossey of Forbes
Magazine and for good reason as we're
still struggling to figure everything
out years later even when binged as many
did in 2020 when the series was coming
to a close and millions were trapped
inside dark proves elusive to understand
the series explores time travel in a way
that few others have and forces you down
a maze of ancestry that can be very
challenging to keep track of unless
you've printed out a family tree we meet
characters when they're young and old we
meet their forebears their descendants
and sometimes the ways in which they are
related isn't always so obvious but
that's hardly the only challenge as we
also discover much of the series is set
in Divergent timelines adding a whole
other layer of complexity the series
never lets up either it continues
introducing new and confusing elements
right up until the end giving you no
time to get acclimated to changes and
fluctuations in time and dimension
like a turbocharged X-Files Fringe
follows an FBI agent thrown into the
world of the bazaar this series also
deals with more than just aliens in the
Paranormal though in fact by the end of
the Show's first season it has
introduced an entire parallel Earth in
an alternate timeline that is seemingly
at war with our own with multiple
versions of the same characters each
with hidden agendas things only get more
complicated some viewers had trouble
figuring out how things are connected
who is doing what and why then there's
the war between strange visitors from an
alternate future whose own motives seem
to shift from season to season the
problem with this one however might be
the opposite of lost as Fringe seems to
have been planned a little too well at
times the show does a good job of
dropping hints about future storylines
but they are often buried a bit too deep
the series may have bitten off a little
more than it could Chew in season 4
where both realities merge and still
makes for a confusing viewing experience
today meanwhile stories that push the
envelope with intentional misdirects
only serve to further muddy the waters
with a vast and intricate mythology that
can be hard to understand there are
still plenty of questions left
unanswered on Fringe
we've seen shows that are confusing
because of intricate webs of plot and
stories that were written on the Fly and
are filled with plot holes but the OA is
something else entirely a series that is
baffling but might have been
comprehensible were it not
unceremoniously canceled before it could
resolve its biggest questions a series
that ends on one of the most
jaw-dropping twists in TV memory it begs
for a follow-up season that never came
the OA Stars Brent Marling as a young
blind woman who has been missing for
seven years but pops up with a new name
and her vision restored she speaks only
to a small group of allies and reveals
that more missing persons can be saved
through a strange dimensional portal
that serves as a Gateway between
multiple Realms but if that sounds
strange wait until you get to the more
magical and mystical parts of the show
including characters who suddenly
manifest Supernatural Powers this
includes one young woman who can
communicate across realities a psychic
nightclub octopus a shadowy Mystic with
a mysterious past robots and a Quantum
Leap style Body transfer that allow
characters to inhabit their own selves
in other realities think you're confused
after that brief description wait until
you watch it just don't expect to get
any answers as we're still trying to
figure it out even knowing we will never
get a resolution
decades before every other entry on this
list the British sci-fi mystery thriller
The Prisoner was well known for its
mystifying story and mind-bending
visuals due to the technological
limitations of the era it's remembered
more for sheer awareness rather than
special effects making the prisoner a
spiritual precursor to the likes of Twin
Peaks what's it all about
Sudan and I'll tell you
the series starred Patrick mcguin as a
secret agent who resigns from his post
only to be abducted and held captive on
a strange Island where nothing is as it
seems beyond its odd nature The Prisoner
became a groundbreaking Landmark series
that influenced multiple genres but
despite its Legacy is arguably one of
the greatest single season TV shows of
all time it's also one of the most
confusing ever produced magoon's
intelligence agent is only ever called
number six while his captors attempt to
break his will week after week for some
nebulous purpose meanwhile strange sites
like giant balloons that can
incapacitate people as quaint as they
might seem to audiences today where
unlike anything anyone had seen at the
time but beyond its unusual style the
story is less than literal playing out
largely in metaphor and allegory with
every prop and plot beat seemingly
hiding some kind of deeper meaning and
significance a series meant to be
experienced and pondered the story had
little in the way of a concrete
conclusion and fans have debated its
meaning for nearly 60 years
foreign